Brenda I've seen a lot of storyboards
that you and Roger kind of worked on and
it was it looks to me like you guys were
almost like one brain kind of being put
together and at the same time I'm
understand you had a sequence of the the
wolf fight sequence where afterwards
Belle and the Beast which I'm sure was a
very important that relationship was a
very had to work and I think you had
Tracy and Hepburn in your head about
that am I correct that that was some
inspiration for the way you approached
those characters at that point or talk
about working on that kind of
relationship um yeah I mean I love the
old Tracy Hepburn films and and yeah
they were partly in my head but partly
um you know looking at beasts character
and how grumpy he had been throughout
the beginning of the film so I thought
well he's gonna be a big baby
you know ow you know like so you know I
thought well you know he's gonna yell at
her but Belle's gonna yell right back
you know that's like and it's it was
just a back and forth and it was very
Tracy Hepburn and but I remember
pitching it for the first time and
Howard Ashman was in the room and he
goes that's it that's just that is it
you know and everything then I was I was
a horrible pitcher to be quite honest
and so Jeffrey came in a few days later
and I pitched it again and I totally
tanked it and and Howard's there no it's
great
you gotta say so Howard saved that
sequence so I'm going to skip to mark
and come back to page so mark you worked
on a lot on Bill and Bill and there were
several people that worked on her
because she's in the whole movie and
so it was a huge character to
concentrate so could you talk a little
bit about I I think Belle is was they're
still making strides in animation and in
movies about the way women are portrayed
but bill I think had a special unique
quality for a Disney film in particular
could you talk about that process of
developing that character
well she first let me just give a shout
out to James Baxter and I learn to cook
were kind of the other two heads of our
kind of three-headed monster
I was I was located at the Florida
studio at the time so I was kind of the
head Bell guy ding dong in in Florida
but but yes Bell is very unique and one
of the things that makes her unique is
is in the lineup of our leading ladies
she's probably the oldest and not that
her age is old old but she is compared
to say Ariel who was 16 you know she's
like I'm 16 daddy you know but Belle is
older much more mature and I always
thought that that was a unique very
unique quality to her so she she kind of
knew her mind she knew kind of what she
wanted to do she wasn't looking for a
new world so much as she you know was
really comfortable with herself
but she loved her father and she was
willing to do things you know out of
that love for for him particularly and I
think they know that was a really unique
situation plus the fact and Brenda kind
of alluded to it is the fact that they
she and Beast weren't it's not love at
first sight that there's an actual
relationship that you see grow
throughout the film that I think is very
magical and what makes this film very
magical so Paige I believe you recorded
all of the songs for this film with a
live orchestra and this went straight
through and you talked about the what an
experience that was and and what you
remember from that oh it was amazing we
were in the it was the basically the
full Philharmonic and we were there and
we were singing live and Richard was
with me immersing in and we were waiting
for miss Lansbury to sing her song and
we heard that she was trepidatious about
it and I will never forget it miss
Lansbury Angela
when you sang your first take of Beauty
and the Beast there wasn't a dry eye in
the studio and I'm told that was the
take they went with in the film and I
had idolized Angela Lansbury my whole
career and when I first came to New York
at 17 I was I was sneaking into the
second act of gypsy to see Angela play
mama rose so it was a great honor and so
that was actually more important than
what I sang did you see her do that okay
so what was your key to understanding
Bell or and when you were creating the
character what was your you know Bell is
really she's an embodiment of so many
different people between you know the
writers the directors the animators the
artists I mean she's really there maybe
25 people that created Belle that who
share Belle with me and I think the most
incredible thing about this movie is
that I've never worked on a project on
Broadway or anywhere where every single
person every artist director person
writing actor whether it's an assistant
that works on the film everyone had the
same vision of what the film should be
and people sacrifice input he goes aside
to make this as perfect as a film that
could be and and nobody was willing to
to not give it 150% and I think that's
partly why it's going to be it's going
to be a classic for all time